digamos que tenemos la fracción 9
decimos y le queremos sumar la fracción
un sexto a que va a ser igual cuál va a
ser el resultado cuando vemos estas
fracciones nos damos cuenta de que
tienen denominadores diferentes y no es
obvio cómo vamos a sumar esto y lo que
tenemos que hacer es buscar un
denominador común y convertir estas dos
fracciones en fracciones que tengan un
denominador común y un denominador común
es un múltiplo de estos dos
denominadores del 10 y del 6 entonces
cuál es un múltiplo del 10 y del 6 y lo
mejor es que encontremos un mínimo común
múltiplo y vamos a empezar con el
denominador mayor que en este caso es el
10 el 10 es divisible entre 6 no no lo
es el 20 es divisible entre 6 no el 30
es divisible entre 6 este si 30 es
divisible entre 6 entonces lo que
hicimos fue buscar entre los múltiplos
de 10 y preguntarnos cuál es el menor
múltiplo de 10 que sea divisible
y ese va a ser 30 y puede reescribir
estas fracciones como algo sobre 30 y
empiezo con 9 sobre 10 como escribo esto
como algo sobre 30
estoy multiplicando el denominador por 3
y si no quiero cambiar el valor de la
fracción entonces tengo que hacer lo
mismo con el numerador tengo que
multiplicarlo por 3
ahora estoy multiplicando el numerador
por 3 y el denominador por 3 y eso no
cambia el valor de la fracción entonces
9 por 13 es igual a 27 otra vez nueve
décimos y 27 treinta bosch representan
el mismo número solo lo estoy
reescribiendo y ahora con el denominador
30 eso es muy útil porque ahora puedo
reescribir un sexto con el denominador
30 un sexto es igual a que sobre 30 y
los animales que poseen el vídeo y
piensen en esto
entonces qué hacemos para pasar del 6 al
30 tenemos que multiplicar por 5 si
multiplicamos el denominador por 5
también tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 5 entonces uno por 5 es
igual a 5 así que 9 décimos es igual a
27 30 vos y un sexto es lo mismo que 530
vos y ahora podemos sumar esto lo
hacemos directamente a un número de 30
vos le sumamos otro número de 30 vos 27
35 30 vos va a ser igual a 27 más 5 30
vos que por supuesto va a ser igual a 32
30 vos y si queremos podemos reducir
esta fracción tenemos un factor común
entre 32 y 30 los dos son divisibles
entre dos y podemos dividir el numerador
y el denominador entre dos el numerador
dividido entre 2 es igual a 16 y el
denominador dividido entre 2 es igual a
y esta es igual a 16 15 años el 15 caben
el 16 una vez y nos queda un quinceavo
todo esto es igual a un entero y un
quinceavo vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
digamos que queremos sumar un medio más
11 doceavos más 11 doceavos y los anima
que pausa en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo
como lo hicimos antes vamos a buscar un
denominador común si tuvieran el mismo
denominador podríamos resolverlo
inmediatamente pero tenemos que buscar
un denominador común porque ahora no son
iguales queremos encontrar un múltiplo
común entre el 2 y el 12 y queremos
encontrar el que sea menor y como lo
hicimos antes vamos a empezar por el
denominador más grande que es el 12 si
dividimos 2 entre 12 es igual a 1 así
que es el menor múltiplo de 12 y vamos a
ver si es divisible entre 2 y si si lo
es podemos dividir 12 entre 2 así que el
12 es el mínimo común múltiplo entre el
2 y el 12 entonces podemos escribir
estas fracciones como algo sobre 12 así
que un medio es igual a que sobre 12
bueno cuando vamos del 2 al 12
multiplicamos por 6 así que también
multiplicamos el numerador por 6 y vemos
que un medio y 6 doceavos es lo mismo
uno es la mitad de dos y seis es la
mitad de 12
y cómo es que vivimos 11-12 a vos como
algo sobre 12 bueno esto ya está escrito
como algo sobre 12 no lo tenemos que
cambiar lo escribimos igual
y ahora estamos listos para sumar y esto
va a ser igual a 6 + 11
sobre 12 tenemos 6 doceavos más 11
doceavos esto es lo mismo que 6 + 11
sobre 12 y esto es igual a 17 doceavos
si lo queremos escribir como un número
mixto tenemos que el 12 cabe en el 17
una vez y nos quedan 5 12 a 2 y
escribimos 1 y 5 12 a vos
vamos a hacer un ejemplo más esto es
extrañamente divertido digamos que
queremos sumar tres cuartos más un
quinto cual será el resultado de esto
una vez más pausa en el vídeo para que
tratan de resolverlo tenemos diferentes
denominadores y queremos reescribir
estas fracciones para que tengan el
mismo denominador
tenemos que encontrar un múltiplo común
el mínimo común múltiplo entonces cuál
es el mínimo común múltiplo entre el 4 y
el 5 vamos a empezar con el número mayor
y buscar sus múltiplos e ir
incrementando los hasta que encontremos
uno que sea divisible entre 4 5 no es
divisible entre 4 pies no es divisible
entre 4 bueno no es exactamente
divisible entre 4 que es lo que estamos
buscando 15 no es exactamente divisible
entre 4 y 20 si es divisible entre 4 5
por 4 es igual a 20 entonces lo que
podemos hacer es describir estas
fracciones con el 20 como denominador
podemos escribir 3
cuartos como algo sobre 20 para ir del 4
al 20 tenemos que multiplicar por 5 y
tenemos que hacer lo mismo con el
numerador 3 por 5 es igual a 15 todo lo
que hice fue multiplicar el denominador
por 5 4 por 5 es igual a 20 y
multiplicar el numerador por 5 3 por 5
es igual a 15 tres cuartos
es lo mismo que 1520 abós y de este lado
tenemos un quinto que es igual a que es
sobre 20 bueno si vamos del 5 al 20
tenemos que multiplicar por 4 así que
hacemos lo mismo con el numerador
tenemos que multiplicar este numerador
por 4 para obtener 4 veinteavos ahora
este tres cuartos más un quinto es igual
que 15-20 abós más 4 veinteavos y cuál
es el resultado bueno 15 4 es igual a 19
veinteavos y lo hicimos